we will try talking to our caller from
the nine one seven area code caller from
907 if you can hear me tell me your name
and tell me what your question is today
hey David
my name is Michael I'm calling out of
New York City and I was actually just
calling about what Trump administration
might mean for the future of you know
the White House politic like do you see
any future administration's possibly
taking any easy way because of all the
constant troubles that the Trump you
know administration it seems to be in do
you see any anything like that happening
oh yeah I mean the Trump presidency and
the way in which they've handled
themselves completely up ends what would
be considered normal and acceptable for
any president so even if you imagine
this is a blip in the radar and that
right after Trump is done we are going
to go back to sort of politics as usual
which has many many problems but is far
less ridiculous I guess you would say
than the Trump administration this has
opened the door at the local state and
national level for all sorts of insanity
to be considered relatively acceptable
because what Trump is doing mostly is
being considered acceptable by a lot of
this country when we think back to
Obama's tan suit scandal yeah I mean
that's just completely laughable now the
Republicans would make that charge if we
have a Democratic president going
forward say one wins in 2020 and they
try to levy that same attack it's just
kind of fall flat on its face I hope so
but I that my main concern though
Michael is that Trump has set a
precedent where now maybe Kid Rock we
would be would be elected in Michigan
right I mean so i think that the door
has been opened to seen these clueless
characters as possibly legitimate
elected officials and that's the
scariest part to me you know yeah
absolutely uh do you think that for for
the voters is this going to be a pattern
and in future elections is celebrity
going to be more now something not
necessarily required for a candidate but
definitely sought you know among voters
because I know as if you know you have
people like
kanye west and the rock all talking
about possible
you know presidential one and it just
seems to really be taking value in my
opinion anyway it is completely thinking
about yeah you're absolutely right and
you know the only this will only be
useful if it makes us say oh yeah we're
never going to do that again but the
fact that trump still has a high 30s
approval rating suggests to me that
there are many people who are very open
to another one of these types of
candidates alright Michael thanks for
the call
always great to hear from our callers in
New York City